[Music]
this was fun
wait we haven't even had sex again yet
i'm just not that kind of girl i only
have sex once on the first date
i'm just gonna call an uber
[Music]
your travel will be ready soon as he
puts on his pants
what you learn by oh crush i have to
tell you something bye
i've been dating this girl she's white a
white girl
hey you can't look like you and male
white girl it's okay we hate harris
i wonder who that could be i'm guessing
it's a young single pakistani woman
this is zubaida for your files your
x-files
that's your favorite show huh the truth
is out there
are you judging pakistan's next top
model you know how we have arranged
marriage in my culture
oh my god i'm so stupid can you imagine
a world in which we end up together
i don't know i'm looking for emily
gardner she was checked in tonight
there's an infection we put her in a
medically induced coma
coma you should call her family thank
you come on
we're gonna handle things from here i
think i'm just going to wait anyway i
broke up i'm not sure why you're here
i'm just going to stay for a second
it's the seat
[Music]
is that lady still looking at me
so uh 9 11. i've always wanted to have a
conversation with
people you've never talked to people
about 911
you can't rhyme it you try to find a
word and nobody can rhyme
okay
yeah so you would win yeah
[Music]
let me give you some advice come on love
isn't easy
that's why they call it love
[Music]
i don't really get that i thought i
could just start saying something and
something small would come out
hey guys how was the party it was really
fun aces
he's wearing a woman's sweater and he's
drunk well he didn't drive drunk and
he's home before curfew so
that's what i thought we got me yeah
we're good parents yeah okay all right
fake young woman good morning
my name's simon for the most part my
life is totally normal
i have a family that i actually like and
there's my friends we do everything
friends do
we drink way too much diced coffee we
walk gorging on carbs
so i'm just like you except i have one
huge ass secret
hey i like your your boots
i said i like your your boots
goodbye nobody knows i'm gay
[Music]
have you seen the new post about the
closeted gay kid at school
what who do you think it is
can i call you back
[Music]
dear blue i'm just like you
this was a mistake
it's nice to know there's another guy at
school with the same secret when did you
first realize
it was a bunch of little things like my
first girlfriend i think i'm falling in
love with you
wow thank you be right back
wasn't my proudest moment
sometimes i think i'm destined to care
so much about one person it nearly kills
me
me too i'm done living in a world where
i don't get to be who i am
i deserve a great love story and i want
someone to share it with
anyway
have you ever been in love i think so
these last few years it's almost like i
can feel you holding your breath
i'm supposed to be the one that decides
when and where and who knows that's
supposed to be my thing
disclaimer this is about to get romantic
as f
you're not in a happy are you she's cute
but she's just not really my type
not because she's black i love black
women not like you know i have a thing
for black women i just i
just i just love all women
the only way to fly
is on
[Applause]
mom and dad what's going on here over
the years at our family gathering
you two show up and you ruin it
i want you to bring a date to your
sister's wedding we don't want you
showing up
stag and riling each other up we don't
rile each other
we never get riled up
we'll shape up for you genie we gotta
find the right girls for this where do
we even go
what we're about to do something awesome
i'm here with mike and dave stengel they
are looking for dates for their sister's
wedding in hawaii let's make these guys
take us to hawaii we're looking for nice
girls
we're going to look respectable as
they're leaving
it's all part of the plan
are you okay i am now i saved your life
she's okay you save your life yeah
grandma i'd meet alice she's super smart
tatiana she's a school teacher
the key to teaching children is is
repetition you'd be surprised how stupid
they are
let's play bocce could we take it easy
absolutely not we should let them lose
with dignity
which is what i'd like to think we would
[Applause]
[Music]
do
that sounds like you guys are like
watching porno or no they have the rod
father
i don't know if we're gonna get it
though if we haven't seen the godfather
i'm a freak little [ __ ] who are these
girls does this mean making us look cool
oh my gosh she's superman you're kind of
much don't ever do that i can do
anything that they can do
is it okay she looks like burn victim
barbie
and you're black ken going down
25 years of marriage you have nothing to
say
i'll just say it i slept with someone if
you keep talking
[Applause]
you're getting a divorce yeah amy heard
you crying in the bathroom
we all thought it was cancer oh thank
god
yeah just my relationship
[Music]
hi can i wear your drink uh-huh let's
get out of here wanna get out of here
what are you doing later i don't know i
do there's lots of beautiful women in
this bar but i can't take my eyes off of
you it's time to go home
oh it's forward of you but okay should i
pull the car around you've been drinking
i'll drive
hey ladies man guy any tips of the trade
your wife cheated on you because you
lost sight of who you are as a man
let's take that straw to your mouth it
looks like you're sucking on it
okay you're sitting there with a
supercuts haircut
and you're wearing a 44mm you should be
wearing 42 regular credit card
where are your wallets did you sleep
with them
geez god yeah probably you would
you got to take control of your manhood
pal can you put on some clothes please
i'm sorry this is bothering you
[Music]
beautiful
what do you want to do with me i want to
show you after my ex-wife make her
really jealous
i met a girl and she is a game changer
she's your soul mate right go get her
back wow how old are you
i'm in love with her and i don't know
what to do about it
[Music]
i don't know when you and i stopped
being us you know when i told you that i
had to work late i really went to see
the new twilight movie by myself
[Music]
seriously it's like you're photoshopped
you're cutting it closed oh come on
good morning miss tate
[Music]
i need you around this weekend you have
a problem with that
no i i just my grandmother's 90th
birthday so i was going to go home and
it's fine i'll cancel it
is that your family yes they tell you to
quit every single day
margaret tate's office this isn't about
my second raise is it margaret your visa
application is denied you're being
deported
deported it's not like i'm an immigrant
or something i'm from canada
if you're deported you can't work for an
american company if there was any way at
all that we could make this thing work
pardon the interruption um
[Music]
i understand the predicament but there
is something that you should know
we are uh we're getting married
who is getting you and i you and i are
getting married yes
we are getting married yes can't fight
can't find a love like ours so uh uh
are we good make it all legal we'll put
this whole thing behind us
i'm not gonna marry you if you don't
you'll be on the street all alone
looking for a job
have the two of you told your parents
about your secret love we're going to
their place this weekend
where's that alaska alaska
where is sandra's room he'll sleep in
here with you we'd love to
snuggle don't we huge snugglers
breakfast for the happy couple
oh my god what is that i'm sorry what is
it it's the morning
how can you be around someone that made
your life so miserable
sweetie honey some proposals change you
why don't you get married here tomorrow
let's see a kiss let me just do it
really fast
for better or worse
give her a real kiss
[Music]
sandra bullock hello ryan reynolds oh
oh my god why are you aware
the proposal maybe a tad loose in
certain areas
i'm a bit chesty to begin with it's like
an easter egg
there they are
where are you going i'm going home i
know breaking up sucks but you know
what's even worse
wasting a night in new york city give it
to me
let me teach you how to be single go get
us some drinks
okay no you don't buy the drinks boys
buy the drinks
not with this wallet okay with the
sausage wallet
[Music]
hey what's up y'all i don't know why i
just said y'all you all
would have taken just as much time oh my
god can i have two margaritas
oh my god
i'm worth it you need to get out
you're in my apartment this is not
my apartment sorry you were great last
night was i
i can't remember you're pretty girl this
is new york city there's like a billion
people outside that door
in every male female friendship there's
total number of drinks four
five and if you hit that it means you
would definitely have sex if i had more
than five drinks i'd hook up with you
my drink number is 27. i wouldn't even
touch myself on less than 24.
i'm on a one-night stand what about the
guy over there no
he's too young i'm ken is this one of
those fetish things where you're
like a foot fetish am i the foot do you
want to
be the foot to no drama no drama
you have to be at work in like 30
minutes i can do this in 20.
step one that stuff is for babies babies
with hangovers
are we good payment accepted let's go
[Music]
welcome to the party if tom texts you
wait four hours to respond and if you
use an emoji i will tip-punch you
no emoji oh
the thing about being single is you
should cherish it
oh my god stop having a moment
you really need to get that taken care
of what do you mean i barely have any
hair
you should close your legs there's a
reason i stopped watching duck dynasty
is that tom hanks from castaway
seriously it's like gandalf is staring
right at me no
penis shall pass
[Music]
morning morning we have problems oh joy
there are no problems only solutions
i should warn you this guy's a little
rough around the edges say hello to our
new guest commentator
who's this delightful creature i'm your
producer i like your woman on top
stick to the script you hear my voice
just do what i say promise you'll talk
dirty
guess what i met a surgeon last night
well you know what that means
what i'd stick his fingers
now listen men are very visual now that
there's a bra oh i love how you assume
all men are as perverse as you are
oh i don't assume i know so did the
surgeon ask you out oh my
god not yet if you do exactly as i say
you'll get this guy you're really that
confident
all right deal i'm gonna make this guy
your [ __ ]
rule number one we have to teach you
flirting i know how to flirt but the
[Music]
what if what he's saying isn't funny
that's irrelevant for men
self-improvement ends at toilet training
now that was perfect real or fake you'll
never know
wow you look great oh i was just doing
the dishes
[Music]
i think he likes you he's such a great
guy yeah he's creepy
you're such a man [ __ ] why am i a man
[ __ ] you're telling me you've never
slept with the fun bag twins
i only slept with the one who could read
i'm spending my money
would you stop doing that why is it
turning you on
maybe i think i kind of like it really
and i'm wearing this sucker
the ugly truth
[Music]
we've been dating for over a year now
and i think it's about time people met
my beautiful girlfriend
what about us taking an adventure east
like queens
singapore colin's wedding don't you want
to be my family
i hardly know anything about them every
time i bring them up it changes the
subject maybe his parents are poor and
he has to send them money
so take a bite and get you checked into
first test nick i can't afford this so
your family is rich
quite comfortable that is exactly what a
super rich person would say
1.2 million the nick you're dating is
nick young yeah you guys know them or
something else yeah they're just the
biggest developers in all of singapore
damn right just like the asian bachelor
these people aren't just rich they're
crazy rich now you really should have
told me that you're like the prince
william of asia that's ridiculous
much more of a harry mom this is rachel
chu
she just thinks you're some like
unrefined banana
there's a few fingers yellow on the
outside a white on the inside do
something crazy
i chose to raise a family for me it was
a privilege
but for you you may think it's
old-fashioned don't you want nick to be
happy
i know you're not what nick needs she's
like trying to play a game of chicken
with me thinking i'm gonna swerve like a
chicken but you can't swerve you gonna
roll up and be like
box [ __ ] okay maybe like not as
aggressive
i met a girl i fell in love and i want
to marry her you're nicholas
young you're untouchable but rachel's
not have you prepped rachel to face the
wolves
you know i'm back like i never left i
really admire you
it takes guts coming all the way over
here facing ex family another day
another breath i know this much you will
never be
enough you know it's about time someone
stood up to auntie eleanor
but you not me oh god chicago i was over
here
[Music]
[Applause]
ever since i can remember my family has
been my whole life rachel
rachel if nick chose me he would lose
his family and if he chose his family
he might spend the rest of his life
resenting you you nasty you got a nasty
you got nastier
[Music]
are you excited for tomorrow is tomorrow
saturday no
it's the first day of school yeah i'm
not gonna go to that
but it's mandatory oh
elizabeth you shouldn't be teaching i
mean i can't think of anyone less suited
to being a teacher
i don't need a blackboard or a classroom
to set an example
so stupid morons
hey elizabeth you know like grab a bite
sometime you still a gym teacher
i am yeah then no okay cool well awesome
this one great all right now on
my full-time job is finding a guy who's
going to take care of me hi there
scott de la court elizabeth halsey on
the new sub how the watch is that a
jaeger lecouch
the family business i love how his eyes
sparkle when he smiles
i want to sit on his hey guys
so did you and your wife just moved to
town i'm not married i actually just got
out of a relationship
she has such a big heart enormous if i
got a new pair of boobs he'd be all over
me but it's really expensive
yeah and you gotta get two of them who
knows maybe you'll win the bonus
damn it what bonus to the state test
whichever teacher has the highest going
class gets a bonus things are about to
change around here
recess is over we're having our car wash
this weekend last year's car wash raised
six thousand dollars
let's do this
[Music]
lauren richmond's dad called he said we
should have a car wash every weekend
[Music]
that's bonkers
[Music]
there is no way that lebron will ever be
jordan call me when lebron has six
championships
it's the only argument i need sean
now who has the answer to my question
you chubs he's
um whoa
wait twilight what do we talk about in
class don't throw at her throw through
her
sign my yearbook hold my balls
let me just break it down for you the
whole time you're rooting for this
hemingway guy to survive the war and to
be with the woman that he loves
four o'clock in the morning can't
somebody say hey let's have a good
ending to the story
i can't apologize you know what i will
do i will apologize on behalf of ernest
hemingway
because that's who's to blame here yeah
have ernest hemingway call us and
apologize to us too
what are you gonna do with yourself
getting trim getting really fit for
nikki patrick she left
she's gone doc i have one incident
i come home from work i see my wife's in
the shower i pull the curtain back
so yeah i snapped
[Music]
hey tiffany this is pat you look nice
thank you
i'm not flirting with you i didn't think
you were
look i think you're really pretty but
i'm married okay so am i no that's
confusing he's dead
wait what's happening
[Music]
since i hear about you just getting out
from the loonie bay guys
i thought you said you had it together
you were solid i am solid i was solid
with the game
i don't know
oh what the hell i just want us to be
friends so how did you lose your job
hi having sex with everybody in the
office everybody i was very depressed
after tommy died we don't have to talk
about it
thanks how many were there don't let
tiffany get you in trouble she's my
friend why would you say that
there's this dance thing i can only do
it if i have a partner oh i'm not gonna
dance with you so is this the girl you
wrote about
you wrote about me she's fine she is my
friend with an f a capital f
poor friend let me tell you you got to
pay attention to science
when life reaches out with a moment like
this it's a sin if you don't reach back
from the talents of sin if you don't
reach back
really this is what i believe to be true
you have to do everything you can
you have to work your hardest if you
stay positive you have a shot at a
silver lining
wait what's this what i thought you were
doing i thought you were doing it
[Music]
[Applause]
what's the prognosis fertile myrtle
minus or plus merida's
little pink plus sign is so unholy that
ain't no i just sketch
this is one doodle that can't be undid
home skillet
just tell them i'm pregnant who is the
father it's polly bleaker
polly bleaker
i don't think he had it in him i know
right did you see that coming
yeah but i was hoping she was expelled
her into her drugs or a dwi
anything but this i could like have this
baby and give it to someone that
totally needs it you should look at the
penny saver they have the ads for
parents
yeah desperately seeking spawn
hi i'm vanessa hi i'm the husband this
of course
is juno like the city in alaska no
you're a part-time love friend full-time
friend
when this is all over and we can always
get back together oh were we together
yeah we were once you know
that time you think you're really gonna
do this if i could just
have the thing and give it to you now i
totally would but
i'm guessing it looks probably like a
sea monkey right now
we should let it get a little cuter
right great keep it in the oven
fox searchlight pictures presents a
comedy about
life well i thought you were the kind of
girl who knew when to say when
i don't really know what kind of girl i
am and the bumps
along the way your little girlfriend
gave me the stink eye in art class yes
trina's not my girlfriend all right and
i doubt that she gave you the stink eye
that's just the way her face looks you
know that's just your face
i don't know if i'm even ready to be a
father a big puffy version of junebug
we've been start dealing with things way
beyond my maturity level
i need to know that it's possible that
two people can stay happy together
forever
the best thing you can do is find a
person who loves you
for exactly what you are juno your
parents are probably
wondering where you are i mean i'm
already pregnant so what other kind of
shenanigans can i get into
[Music]